hey there my name is annabelle i'm a
research veterinarian from nigeria
currently i am a research intern at pine
biotech usa i'm interested in the
genomics and transcriptomics of
infectious diseases and with the omics
logic platform and provided with a great
hands-on project-oriented learning
experience in carrying out
bioinformatics research want to get
started on your bioinformatics journey
then come with me to the omixlogic
culture omixlogic learn portal the
website is
learn.omicslogic.com
this will take you directly to the
portal where you can sign in
[Music]
if you don't have an account you can
create an account for free
[Music]
just input your name
email address and a password or
you can sign up using any of your social
media accounts after signing up you need
to input some basic information like
your phone number country occupation and
the university and proceed to sign in
with this
once you've completed your profile you
can go ahead to sign in
since i already have an account i'm just
going to sign in
the next step is to update your profile
you and your mentors can track your
progress through your profile
click your email id and it will take you
to your profile
it is important to input your full name
as this will be the name that will
appear on your certificates earned
so
upload a picture
connect your social media accounts and
write a brief bio about yourself your
research interests and your research
background
you end points as we go through the
courses so start learning the
introductory cost work is absolutely
free on the portal you can check out the
courses there's a section of courses
specifically handpicked just for you
you can check out the awesome research
projects carried out by other students
in the omixlogic programs
if you have gone through the courses and
the projects and would love to apply
your knowledge in doing research then
check out the omics logic research
fellowship well thank you for watching
keep learning
[Music]
you